let's talk about the Devil's Advocate
okay the folks who are right now saying
well Ripple deserves this because behind
closed doors they were doing XYZ and for
the way Ripple was formatted if I
remember 80 of that 100 billion right is
it 100 billion token I said am I sent it
correctly of which a 80 day gifted 20
they kept right right today's market cap
is around 37 billion dollars the fully
diluted will be around 80 billion
dollars that's kind of where they are
today correct with numbers so some
people from the other side say well
listen these guys were kind of doing a
pump and dumb type of stuff behind
closed doors and Market manipulation and
because there's no regulation they can
kind of do this and you know they used
to say that also about uh uh John McAfee
John McAfee would say it's going to this
let's go into this let's go into this it
would go up he would sell then he would
tell people not to sell and I don't know
whether he did this or not but that was
a lot of criticism because we had McAfee
on as well well one of the big things
that you know we talk in the crypto
Community our guys are like we love
Ripple the technology we love Ripple the
coin we love what it can do for you know
internet National you know money
transactions hate the people who created
it so like that's that seems why is that
though why why are people saying that
though well I think because when you
compare it to like Bitcoin right there
was no pre-mined with Bitcoin yeah and
uh you had people allegedly could fairly
mine for it and it was open it was
decentralized from the beginning
they they believe that these executives
are enriching themselves but my answer
to that question is okay go after Brad
Garland house go after Ripple why are
you going after the token why are you
eight years after the fact why are you
going after the teacher that put you
know 500 in the Ripple yeah exactly I've
never met Brad garlinghouse never met
Chris Larson never met the any of the
people at Ripple I'm no Ripple fan those
two names that you just so if people
don't know their Founders I think Chris
is the one that founded Ripple uh Labs
right he's one of the co-founders as
well yeah yes and and they were sued
independently now they the thing about
it Pat is in this case after a 30-month
investig education the SEC didn't
actually allege fraud they investigate
Ripple for 30 months there's no fraud
alleged it is a strict Securities
violation you didn't give proper
disclosures when you made these
transactions and and I say fine go after
them all right I'm not here to defend
them they've got way better lawyers than
me right to defend them but what you're
doing when you go after the token itself
in the secondary market right you're let
me tell you something and I know this
because I've been communicating with 60
000 people it is an absolute fact that
the first time purchasers of xrp
58.2 percent of them had never heard of
the company Ripple they've heard Ripple
the name but they never heard of a
company 58 have never heard of it when
they first they first bought it pure
speculation yeah you know what they do
listen you go on you it was a number
three for a while it was number two
market cap but it's the top three market
cap somewhere like cryptocurrencies is
25 sense so people look at they see
Bitcoin going up they're like hey I can
afford 25 cents right and so so they
were doing that and had no connection to
this company and so to to allege
that those people entered a common
Enterprise with ripple and therefore
it's an investment contract is just it's
taking absurdity to the highest level do
you think that they attacked the soft
target do you think that that they were
looking to set a precedent against the
tokens Ripple made the mistake of
incorporating in the United States and
they went after people that they didn't
think like who pays you like like they
never thought that you know 60
000 coin holders would actually come
together communicate and formulate some
sort of defense against this they
thought they were going after a soft
target and that they were going to
create some case law that that was going
to change the crypto landscape and then
you came in and you you took a dump on
their front lawn well let me tell you I
think what we're talking about here the
people that you know in cryptocurrency
where and what Pat said about people
don't like these Executives or they
don't like the 80 being gifted and
holding back 20 percent if you read the
complaint even though they don't allege
fraud they use fraud like language in
the complaint and it inflames people if
you don't like Ripple and you're like oh
they're going after Ripple I'm not
worried about it but when you read the
complaint and it says that all xrp
holders
all joined into a common Enterprise with
each other and with ripple when they say
that the very nature of the token itself
is an investment contract with ripple
then it becomes very dangerous they're
using in my opinion this case to set the
president that you're talking about so
that if they're successful they can do
what you were saying Pat and regulate
all the cryptocurrency so so so let's go
back to this SEC lawsuit that uh Clayton
you said Clayton did right before the
day before he was done he absolutely
filed this lawsuit I think it's December
20th of 2020 December something of 2020
right after election by the wound this
thing kind of took place
so so the lawsuit is towards the x-harp
xrp holders nothing to do with Brad and
Chris is that what you're saying or are
they going after Brad and Chris as well
separately no they're going after Ripple
and Brad and Chris but they're being so
over Broad in their language that you're
using that they're saying all xrp even
in the secondary Market
that's being traded that all of that's
an unregistered security so one of these
62 000 that that's uh what did they get
in mail did they get and mail something
from the SEC did they get how do they
know they're being part of that lawsuit
okay what happened was basically and and
this was forewarned Clayton and I have a
letter I'm going to give it to you
because I just got it from the SEC after
fighting them for nine months and
threatening to sue them through Freedom
of Information Act but a former uh
fellow Republican SEC commissioner Joe
grunfest on December 17th
uh sent a letter to Clayton and the
Commissioners and said don't do this you
are about to harm innocent xrp holders
and cause more billions in losses than
in any non-fraud case in the history of
this country they warned them and they
still filed it on walking out the door
and so what happened is just as that
former SEC commissioner warned he said
listen if you say that xrp is
unregistered security coinbase is trying
to go public
they're not going to hold it they're not
going to keep it they're not going to
trade it and so the intermediaries the
exchanges and the platforms are going to
delist it and that's what happened and
so coinbase Kraken binance
crypto.com they all said look I'm not
messing with the SEC SCC says the token
itself is an unregistered security we're
delisting it and we're not trading it
and so you have people uh learned that
way and many of these xrp holders
learned of this company named Ripple and
these Executives called Brad
garlinghouse and Chris Larson for the
first time when they got notice on their
wallet and coinbase that said pursuant
to the and it says I could show you on
my phone it says because of the SEC
action against Ripple we are suspending
all trading of xrp and let me tell you
how that impacts people Pat I don't know
if you've ever heard of I trust Capital
right it's basically an IRA for crypto
and it's the biggest one in the country
and they allow you to hold your crypto
just like you can have the Bitcoin
grayscale Bitcoin trust in an IRA right
well they basically have Frozen all of
the people's assets so xrp if they want
to trade it right now they can't if they
want to sell it because xrp goes to five
bucks and and take that gain they can't
this is Robin Hood gme all over again I
mean that's what you can't buy or sell
or trade right now you not on coinbase
on those there are a couple exchanges
like uphold that made the decision that
said this is ludicrous our Securities
lawyers say there's not a unregistered
security we're comfortable maintaining
it but there's like one or two out of 15
and the rest of them delisted and but
those individuals who have that money
that xrp it's frozen so if they had a
life altering event
right their their mother-in-law needed
to go to a nursing home and they needed
to cash couldn't touch it can't touch it
yeah all waiting on this lawsuit to
happen couldn't tell you well that's
that's uh uh uh that's how a lot of
these organizations get the you know
negative uh uh reputation that they do
SEC types of organizations what I'm
talking about but you know when you get
a knock on the door from SEC that's a
real knock yeah it's not just anybody
knocking on your door that's a knock you
got to answer and say here we go again
so how much money is Ripple right now
Brad Chris how much are they using with
legal teams especially the killer the
ridiculous legal team that they have how
much have they already spent you know I
don't know but I wouldn't be surprised
if it's at least a million and a half a
month okay million and a half a month is
what they're spending I mean that's
that's me guessing so so so in in in
full you know if you were to say right
now there's a few things that can happen
right with this case they can settle
which a lot of people are saying is
probably going to end up settling right
let's just say it's going to end up
settling the SEC comes on let's settle
you know 10 million bucks 50 million
bucks 100 million bucks whatever the
numbers that they settle with right fine
here's a check you move on and then the
other one is to say they release they
just kind of say look we're just going
to let it go we're not going to do
anything right now and uh we're not
necessarily going to settle with you
what is the consequences of both both
negative and positive well I think it's
very positive for everyone if there is a
settlement and and give you an example
you could pick the number
Ripple owns 50 billion xrp it's in
escrow and each month one billion gets
released and they use some of it sell it
and then they put it back in escrow
that's 50 billion Pat imagine if xrp
gets to five bucks right there were 250
billion dollars that's significantly
more than more than Stanley and Goldman
Sachs and so if that were to happen and
the SEC were to be worried about the
precedent right the way this case
settles is Gary Gensler is afraid that
an adverse ruling by the judge on Fair
notice where she says listen you can't
go after them you let it happen for
eight years uh you didn't do anything
there's so much on Clarity in the world
in this market uh you allowed them to do
MoneyGram you allowed it to go on
coinbase all those things if that
happens then that precedent would be
usable by cardano and XL limb and every
other who doesn't want that he doesn't
want that that makes sense so if if that
happens when that pressure Point takes
place then you could pick a number you
could if it goes to five bucks for
example if that happens that's uh they
could sell ten percent of the monthly
escrow which would give them 500 million
dollars they could settle for 500
million it would be a huge public win
for Gary ginsler because it would be one
of the highest SEC settlements as long
as it as long as they don't classify the
token as a security but but that
settlement won't happen unless they do
basically what was done for ether in
2018 when Bill Hinman then the director
of Corporation Finance said you know
what we're going to set aside uh the
fundraising and the initial years but
today's token is not a security we would
need some kind of Declaration from the
SEC or the court for that settlement to
happen so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]